power okay a piece that's good
well thank you light for being on now
that ball looked a little strange
there's someone behind me this time
hi how you doing
I can do that too we having a moment
here
what are you taking no no don't no I
don't want to go no don't take me to
your dungeon no oh no please please
leave me alone
oh no oh what are you gonna do to me oh
where you talk awfully thick yellow
lines for a road and I don't think this
is nearly regulation-size Wow where did
you come from
Oh God oh there we go
that's called me
weird Springs froggy fede Wheaties
getting the high score all up in here
whoa
what ah my head exploded all these
delightful delicious things for me to
throw on the floor just willy-nilly like
there wasn't a care in the world it just
makes you realize that there's more to
life than chasing your tail like a dog
when you can just get on the counter
like it bring that down I guess I'll
have to use this your fish bastard yeah
oh yeah obviously they don't stand a
chance anymore basket you think you want
some of me do these already
oh I gotta make sure there's other
diamond bow ski oh my legs are they
working relax they're marking oh my oh
what is what is it what is why I don't
know what why is I gotta just
h/h it up as oh v everything else has
just been abandoned at this point it's
just
H&N that's all I can do and why I don't
even know how I work oh this is where I
need to take them oh I only have two oh
how was I supposed to know this very few
very few of me or very few of other
people's that do I get to play music
like an octave run enough time ah love
octane tune in on time
wait where was I where the hell am i I
didn't what I'm drawing a big middle
finger to that cuz I couldn't see where
it was I don't think you're telling this
I mean II don't know I'm sorry do you
did it I'm gonna murder you murdered by
who
sorry excuse me
what oh one star as if that even bothers
me good yeah hammer the point oh no
these puns aren't working okay I don't
know what the hell that shadow thing was
thing to do with that one I can handle
the monsters with that shadow thing
thanks for watching all of the videos in
this compilation are available in the
description so check them out and if
you'd like to see more in the future
please leave a like to let me know if
you enjoyed this video and you'd like to
see more on a daily basis please
subscribe today or if you're already
subscribed share this video with a
friend thanks again for watching and
I'll see you in the next video bye bye